renommé de la République du Congo
Monsieur Pierre Jacquemot Monsieur
Pierre Jacquemot vous êtes diplomate et
universitaire vous avez été ambassadeur
de France au Kenya au Ghana et
précisément en RDC chef de coopération
dans plusieurs pays d'Afrique et
conseiller économique du président
abdouyouf au Sénégal et actuellement
expert à la Fondation Jean jores vous
êtes conférencier à sciencep et
président d'honneur du Gret l'ONG de
solidarité internationale vous avez
écrit de nombreux ouvrages notamment sur
le développement en Afrique et Monsieur
Vircoulon vous êtes pour votre part
consultant indépendant chercheur associé
à l'ffer depuis 2006 dont vous
coordonnez l'observatoire de l'Afrique
centrale et australe et vos travaux
portent sur les conflits les questions
de sécurité et de gouvernance en Afrique
et vous avez été notamment vous avez
notamment écrit des ouvrages sur la RDC
vous enseignez à sciencep et avez
travaillé pour le ministère des Affaires
étrangères et la Commission européenne
notamment en Afrique du Sud au Kenya et
en RDC la République du démocratique du
Congo est récemment revenu dans
l'actualité avec la reprise
d'affrontement très grave dans le Nord
dans le nord-est du pays entre les
forces gouvernementales et des groupes
armés dont le M23 que le Rwanda est
accusé de soutenir l'ONU a annoncé que
le nombre de personnes déplacées à
l'intérieur du pays s'élevé à près de 7
millions le chiffre le plus élevé jamais
enregistré ces personnes ont grand
besoin d'aide humanitaire au même moment
sont organiser des élections
présidentielles législatives et
provinciales dans le dans un climat de
forte contestation des de fonctionnement
de la démocratie congolaise ces deux
événements sont représentatifs d'une
histoire récente assez tragique pour ce
pays francophone de plus de 100 million
d'habitants le plus vaste le plus vaste
d'Afrique sub-saharienne riche
d'immenses ressources naturelles devenu
indépendant depuis 1960 en tant que
successeur du Congo belge au moment où
la République du Congo succédait à son
côté au moyen Congo français tandis que
la construction démocratique reste
inachevée et que le développement ne
parvient pas à dépassé l'économie
extractive avec des prédations qu' les
prédations qu'elle en crainent la RDC se
débat depuis des décennies dans ce qui
est considéré pour beaucoup d'analystes
comme le conflit le plus meurtrier et de
loin de la depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale cette audition est donc
l'occasion d'avoir un état de des lieux
de la situation actuelle mais aussi d'en
comprendre les origines dans ce pays
francophone qui exprime régulièrement le
souhait d'avoir une coopération plus
approfondie avec la France les relations
de Notre p avec la RDC mais aussi avec
le Rwanda voisin font ainsi
nécessairement partie de l'équation que
vont nous présenter nos deux
invités nous nous sommes mis d'accord
donc au préalable sur la répartition
suivante monsieur jacquem évoquera
l'État congolais avec notamment la
question de la construction démocratique
et la difficulté à se développer ainsi
que les enjeux des élections imminentes
tandis que Monsieur Vircoulon euh se
concentrera plus particulièrement sur la
guerre sans fin dans le nord-est le rôle
des pays limitrophes et des Nations
unies dans cette guerre enfin la
reprise des affrontements récents
malheureusement et donc après cette
exposé liminire nous pourrons avoir un
échange plus approfondi sur le sujet les
sujets qui intéressent plus
particulièrement les membres de la
commission et donc je vous laisse je
vous laisse la parole et puis j'aurai
l'occasion ensuite de prendre les
questions de mes collègues et de leur
passer le micro merci beaucoup pour
d'avoir répondu favorablement à notre
invitation et puis je vous laisse nous
expliquer cette question difficile
ce matin même au téléphone avec coupe le
micro j'étais ce matin même au téléphone
avec un de mes amis qui rentre du
secteur et qui m'expliquer combien la
corruption était un sujet assez
considérable dans ce pays donc si vous
avez quelques éléments sur le sujet on
me dit qu'on ne manque finalement de pas
grandchose dès qu'on a de l'argent et
qu'on peut
payer merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs chers collègues euh je suis
très honoré d'avoir été invité ce matin
pour parler d'un pays où j'ai servi
pendant un certain nombre d'années comme
représentant de notre pays un pays dont
on dit qu'il est un pays d'avenir mais
qu'il le restera longtemps ce ce
compliment perfide qui avait été
appliqué au
Brésil le Congo le traîne depuis 63 ans
maintenant alors pour présenter
brièvement ce ce pays je m' inspirai
d'une tradition congolaise qui consiste
à utiliser des adages ou des proverbes
vous inquiétez pas je n'en citerai que
quatre le premier c'est que à Kinshasa
on dit souvent on ne jaose pas la
profondeur du fleuve Congo avec le petit
doigt en fait qu'est-ce qu'on sait du
Congo aujourd'hui
euh je vous ai mis une carte c'est la
carte du Cadoré ce pays a neuf
voisins parmi lesquels certains
tentèrent de de de lui prendre une un
fragment de territoire
euh un territoire de c'est le deuxème
pays le plus grand du du continent après
l'Algérie
2000 2,3 million de km²r quatre fois la
France c'est un espace particulièrement
contraint du fait de sa taille et qui
souffre d'un manque considérable de
communication euh du fait de enfin et
ceci se traduit par une situation
d'archipel dans le pays
3400 km de route asphalté seulement
combien il y a d'habitants on va vous
dire avec un
chiffre un chiffre à l'unité près plus
ou moins 100 millions en fait c'est faux
le dernier recensement date de
1984 et depuis on extrapole c'està-dire
qu'on applique un taux de fécondité et
un taux de natalité de temps et voilà
donc on sait pas combien il y a de de de
de congolais dans le dans ce territoire
vous avez dit un pays francophone je me
souviens l'occasion du voyage du
président Nicolas
Sarkozi on avait dit que c'était le
premier pays francophone qui venait
juste de dépasser la
France en fait c'est loin d'être
démontré puisquon au Congo on parle le
kikongo le lingala le soili ou le tiluba
d'abord dans
la partie Est qui nous occupera tout à
l'heure les documents d'identité sont
très faibles on estime que un congolais
sur TR une pièce
d'identité donc comme je dirais tout à
l'heure le fichier électoral est
inévitablement douteux deuxè proverbe on
dit le sommeil est un peu la mort se
réveiller le matin pour nous c'est un
véritable miracle c'est un miracle
quotidien en effet l'histoire est
impitoyable et on pourrait dire que dans
ce pays le pire est est par parfois
certain une collègue congolaise d'une
ONG humanitaire me disait il y a peu de
temps à Goma comment peut-on imaginer
autant de malheur tomber sur ma région
lorsqu'ils sont partis les Belges nous
ont accordé l'indépendance mais ont s'y
jeté mais on ai jeté les clés à la mer
cell qui ouvrait les portes du
développement ensuite 32 ans de Mobutu
ensuite les pillage de 91 et 93 à
l'occasion desqueles un de mes collègues
a été tué d'une balle dans la tête
l'ambassadeur le colère en 94 l'avion du
Rwanda en 96 les massacres dans les
camps l'éruption du volcan en 2002
l'accident d'avion qui est rentré dans
le marché central de Goma en 2008
Laurent Kunda en 2008 les Rwandais
encore en 2009 et encore aujourd'hui la
terreur dans les kivous le renversement
de barges quasi hebdomadaire sur le
Congo c'est fini il ne peut plus rien
nous
arriver actuellement dans dans l'est du
pays plus de 120 groupes armés sont
aujourd'hui répertoriés mais on les
trouve au cassaille on les trouve dans
le catanga et on en trouve également à
l'embousure à l'embousure du du flu
Congo les victimes alternent souvent
dans la
résignation au fond de la salle de
l'Institut français de Kinshassa
l'Institut de la gombée des jeunes
m'interrogaient pourquoi Kabila père
a-t-il choisi de remplacer c'est le nom
de zaï un nom portugais adapté d'un mot
africain le nzéré le fleuve par
RDC les Congos les le Congo est-il
condamné à rester en Ray de chucé et ne
jamais monté dans les étage
interrogation des jeunes que j'avais
rencontré à cette
occasion même chose quand vous allez à
l'université surpeuplée de Kinshasa qui
a été conçu par les Belges par les
jésuites pour accueillir 5000 étudiants
qui en compte aujourd'hui sans aucune
extension 25000 eu ils sont tous ils
s'estiment tous des futurs diplômé
sommeur et ils sont dans ce qu'ils
appellent l'économie des désirs
inassouvis 3è proverbe si vous permettez
le chien a beau avoir quatre pates il ne
peut pas emprunter quatre
sememins pourquoi les pouvoirs qui
furent successivement en place au Congo
ne sont-ils pas parvenus à créer les
institutions des institutions robustes
c'est votre question monsieur le
Président est-ce l'incapacité des élites
est-ce la faillite des institutions
inadapté est-ce la rapacité des pays
voisins est-ce que le Congo occupe un
mauvais rôle dans le jeu des grandes
puissances surtout ce fulc pendant
pendant les années
80 en fait derrière les les institutions
formelles et les adhésions verbales à la
démocratie ce cach différent procédés
pour geler complètement le
système en particulier en période
pré-électorale achat de conscience sû
plus ou moins déguisé déstabilisation de
l'opposition transumance des militants
d'un parti à l'autre détournement de la
marchine judiciaire contournement du
fisque symptôme le plus manifeste et
c'est le cas actuellement c'est la
porosité des frontières entre le secteur
public et le secteur
privé toutes ces explications ont une
part de une part de vérité lorsqu'on on
rentre dans l'intérieur dans la
connaissance interne du des réalités de
ce pays des réalités de de la politique
de ce pays la construction de l'État est
annoncée depuis donc 63 ans et demeure
toujours toujours en projet tout comme
la tentative de sortie de de l'état de
pauvreté qui affecte la grande majorité
des Congolais alors qu'a fait Kabila
Kabila fils qui a pris le pouvoir à 29
ans enfin à qui on a confié le pouvoir à
29 ans il n'était pas nécessairement
candidat en janvier 2001 quand son père
a été assassiné par un un cadogo un un
enfant soldat qui s'appelait Rachidi qui
était affecté à sa gadee personnelle
donc il a été brutalement propulsé en
pleine lumière dans un pays d'une rare
complexité qui était caractérisé vous
voyez cette carte par une situation
de
d'archipellisation toute la partie est
était largement contrôlé par des groupes
proches du Rwanda et la partie nord par
des groupes
proches de de l'Ouganda il y a une
époque où pratiquement tous les pays de
la sous-région y compris le zimbabweé
sont intervenus dans dans ce y compris
la naibi sont intervenus dans ce pays
occupant pratiquement les 3/4 du du
territoire donc Kabila fils a hérité de
cette
situation après après son son élection
où il est resté il est resté au pouvoir
pendant 18
ans et remplacé en 2018 par Félice
citsekedi qui est aussi un fils de
fils de l'opposant historique de mobutou
Étienne chissekedi qui était aussi
vierge que lui que Kabila
fils en matière de
pouvoir il se
retrouvait mis en installé comme
président de la République à l'issue
d'un d'un d'un scrutin très
contesté le le ministre des Affaires
étrangères Yv le drillant de l'époque
avait parlé c'est resté d'ailleurs dans
la mémoire des Congolais de compromis
électoral à l'issue de de ce
scrutin et et tienne chissekedi a traîné
avec lui ce procès en
illégitimité pendant pendant une bonne
partie de son son mandat juste pour
donner
quelques éléments très de personnalité
de d'Étienne cissekedi de Félix
chissekedi pardon on dit que c'est un
bon vivant il est humain il est
difficile à cerner pour certains après
visible on dit que c'est un loup dans
une pote de d'agneau un fauxan un joueur
d'échec
euh si le pouvoir isole il aime il aime
être très entouré et sa résidence est
appelée la Nouvelle Jérusalem ce qui
colle assez bien avec un prés pour un
président très croyant qui aime
s'entourer de
pasteur sa présidence de ses dernières
années depuis 2008 depuis 2018 aura été
qualifié d'éléphantesque et de
budgettivor mais son objectif était de
trouver un équilibre entre les
différents cercles qui l'entourait dans
une situation d'une rare
complexité alors vous avez parlé de
corruption moi j'aime pas beaucoup le
mot de corruption mais mais mais peu
importe on va pas faire un débat sur ce
sujet la redistribution
agit agit par capillarité
elle irrigue la toile d'araignée soci
les politiques elle s'alimente sur un
marché public un redressement fiscal
abusif une ponction illégale sur une
entreprise le harcèlement fiscal des
pourcentages de la redistribution vont
croissant de l'agent de base jusqu'au
chef de bureau puis au directeur et
ainsi de suite jusqu'au centre de la
toile rien de très différent avec ce
qu'on connaît dans d'autres dans
d'autres contexte dans d'autres pays je
pense à à l'Asie du Sud-Est par exemple
que je que je connais ou en Amérique
Latine ou dans d'autres pays et voire
des pays européens la corruption tisse
le maillage du pouvoir autour d'un
réseau de complicité renforce la
cohésion interne des groupes et permet
de gérer des alliés les courtisans et de
conforter leur loyauté donc c'est un
mode un mode de fonctionnement que que
par ailleurs je trouve certainement
dominant dans la plupart des pays des
pays de la planète mais euh la
République démocratique du Congo est
blement fonctionne sur ce type de
modèle juste une une question
intéressante peut-être pour vous
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs c'est
qu'est-ce qu'un élu dans le contexte
congolais puisque on est à à à quelques
jours de de l'élection présidentielle
législative et
municipale à chaque élection on entend
les nouveaux élus dire c'est à mon tour
de manger mais j'entends la même chose
au Togo ou au Bénin quand je fais des
observations électorale une fois acquise
légitimé démocratiquement entre
parenthèses la nouvelle position peut
être mise en valeur les acteurs
politiques n'ont pas de référence
idéologique très précise ils sont
attachés surtout à gérer leurs intérêts
et leurs alliances leurs alliances
surtout face à eux les électeurs sont
provisoirement satisfaits de l'argent
reçu le jour du
vote dernier dernier proverbe et je vais
terminer sur ce sujet on
kinsha quand le ventre est vide l'urne
sonne
creux ceci n nous interpelle sur la
question de savoir quelle va être la
participation au élections du 20
décembre alors normalement il a 44
million
d'électeurs c'est un seul tour un seul
tour pour la
présidentielle un cas quand même quasi
unique en
Afrique il y a 22 candidats
le vote n'aura pas lieu dans au moins
deux territoires sur les six que compte
la province du Nord
kivou qui est la 2uxe du pays en nombre
d'électeurs potentiels et on compte 6,9
millions de personnes déplacées ou qui
ont été obligé de quitter leur foyer
l'intérieur du
pays c'est les chiffres qui viennent de
sortir de l'agence des Nations Unies
pour les migration donc c'est autant de
Congolais qui auront des difficultés
pour payer pour voter alors 22 candidats
pour un tour autant de programme et
d'opinion dans une campagne qui a été
marquée par de nombreuses controverses
il y en a encore ce matin sur
l'utilisation du stade de Kinshasa qui
ne pourrait pas être utilisé par un des
gros candidats parce qu'il est en
travaux ou par l'absence de kerosè pour
euh se rendre dans les provinces en
avion et dont sont victime et évidemment
plutôt les
opposants vous avez quatre caillements
importants Félice tissekedi le sortant
le fils de l'
qui qui est le sortant donc qui
bénéficie de de cet avantage surtout
dans un scrutin un tour Denis mwegé que
tout le monde connaît le le célèbre
gynécologue
docteur prix Nobel pardon de la paix qui
est total nov en politique Martin
fayoulou une personnalité intéressante
qui a été batue aux élections de
2018 d'après les églises il a été il
aurait dû gagner ses élections enfin
Moïse katoubi le milliardaire ancien
gouverneur du
Katanga dont on conteste la congolité du
fait que son père n'est pas congolais
mais qui vient de récupérer un certain
nombre de candidats qui ont renoncé non
des moindres il y a une femme Marie José
ifouou qui est la présidence de
l'alliance des élites pour un nouveau
Congo et qui envisage de mettre en place
sa vision de la
combolisation ça veut dire le nettoyage
donc la lutte contre la corruption et et
le
clientélisme quelle est la C principale
des des candidats ce sont les jeunes
entre 18 et 35 ans les jeunes qui
possèdent un
smartphone c'està-dire une audience
potentielle de près de 15 millions de
personnes le taux de participation des
jeunes est très faible je renvoie ce
proverbe quand le ventre est vide l'urne
sonne creux et donc il y a énormément
d'activités ENF énormément de de
discours et de d'initiatives prises dans
cette
direction des jeunes qui pour l'instant
se révèlent plutôt démotivés et résignés
en matière de
politique organiser des élections dans
dans ce pays si vous pouvez passer la
première des diapos si vous voulez s'il
vous plaît
c'est particulièrement compliqué il faut
100000 machines à voter à déployer en 15
jours sans sans les moyens qu'avait en
2018 le Congo qui était les moyens de la
Monusco c'esttait la force des Nations
Unies qui n'a pas été sollicité avec ses
hélicoptères ces moyens logistiques
divers et
variés comme vous le savez beaucoup de
localités sont complètement coupées du
pays le procès verbau n'existe pas les
en raison d'un retard du fournisseur
sud-africain et la Commission électorale
indépendante vient de de se retourner
vers la Chine pour trouver une solution
euh une solution à à ce problème quoi
qu'il en soit la sécurité restera le
problème majeur euh la sécurité aux
alentours des bureaux de vote dans un
certain nombre de de sites sur les
observation note que l'Union européenne
vient de renoncer pour des raisons de
sécurité à déployé des observateurs sur
l'ensemble du territoire il n'y aura que
H observateurs qui resteront à
Kinshasa vous connaissez tous la carte
vous voyez où est situé kinsasa euh ce
n'est pas bougimaille ce n'est pas
vraiment le le cœur le cœur du pays
enfin c'est important de dire que la
Conférence épiscopale la SCCO va mettre
en en place 20000 observateurs et qui
sont très qualifiés pour surveiller le
comptage et la transmission des
résultats font un un système de double
voilà j'en termine pour dire quels sont
les les thèmes de campagne qu'on a
entendu la première c'est la lutte
contre l'enrichissement
illicite certains proposent d'appliquer
la peine de mort aux personnes étant
ayant été reconnu détournement sur fond
public au moins trois candidats qui
évoquent ceci étant la peine de mort
existe au Congo elle n'a jamais été
appliquée est toujours commué en en en
prison en peine de prison à perpétuité
deuxème sujet important la subvention au
carburant ça c'est un phénomène c'est un
problème qu'on rencontre dans d'autres
pays africains Nigéria par
exemple la subvention a été supprimée
par sur injonction des des institutions
financière international au prétexte
qu'elle a un coût très important pour
les caisses de
l'État sujet intéressant le forage
pétrolier peut-on dans un des plus
anciens parcs naturels d'Afrique le parc
de la viunga opérer des forages
pétroliers les mines artisanales dont on
parlera peut-être tout à l'heure de
doivent-ell disparaître les mines de
cassitérite les mines d'or les mines de
de coletan et cetera et enfin la
question de la liberté de la presse
c'est également un sujet récurrent voilà
les principaux thèmes qui sont évoqués à
l'occasion de cette cette
campagne ceci
étant on peut avoir une position Plô je
termine ce sera ma conclusion
euh moins moins péjorative moins
négative que celle que je pourrais
laisser entendre euh plus vous rentrez
en profondeur dans ce pays plus vous
apprenez de sa complexité et plus vous
mesurez tout ce qui vous reste à
apprendre donc vous êtes dans une
position de de grande humilité par
rapport à la richesse et à la complexité
d'un tel pays et vous arrivez vous
parvenez à révéler des initiatives des
énergies tout à fait tout à fait
spectaculaires ici ou là y compris dans
les régions les plus enclavées qui sont
les les régions forestières du du centre
du pays
et on peut on peut glisser sur le moyen
long terme vers une position plus plus
optimiste en en se disant que ce géant
endormi finira tôt ou tard par se
réveiller et par se mouvoir dans la
bonne direction par la force des saues
peut-être plus que par la volonté des
des gouvernants et je j'aime citer le le
champ le champ euh l'hyne national que
sentent les écoles que les enfants des
écoles chaque matin unis par le sort
dressons nos front longtemps courbés par
le labeur nous btirons un pays plus beau
qu'avant je vous
remercie merci beaucoup pour ces
informations monsieur Vircoulon je je
propose de vous laisser un quart d'heure
parce qu'après je dois laisser la parole
à mes collègues pour des questions
éventuelles merci beaucoup vous la
parole merci monsieur le Président euh
mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
voilà merci beaucoup donc vous m'avez
demandé de vous parler plus
particulièrement du conflit dans l'Est
de la RDC qui est en effet en règle
générale la raison pour laquelle on
parle de la RDC dans l'actualité puisque
dans les trois provinces que vous pouvez
voir sur la carte le Nord kivou le Sud
kivou et l'itouri euh ça fait à peu près
30 ans maintenant ou un peu moins de 30
ans euh qu'il y a une situation de de
violence structurelle et une
conflictualité que j'appellerai pas sans
fin mais une conflictualité qui est
vraiment structurelle alors euh je vais
pas vous euh enfin l'historique
évidemment serait un peu long donc je
vais vous le résumer très rapidement euh
on peut le faire remonter à 1996 quand
l'armée rwandaise est entrée au N kivou
euh pour poursuivre les interamoué qui
étaient les génocidaires du du génocide
Rwanda qui s'était installé dans l'Est
du
Congo et cela c'est'est poursuivi par la
création de lafdl qui a mis au pouvoir
le président Laurent desiré Kabila et
lafdl n'était qu'une création de
l'Ouganda et du Rwanda et donc Laurent
Désiré Kabila a été mis au pouvoir et a
chasser Mbutu grâce à ces deux armées
ceci s'est ensuite corsé si je puis dire
dans la mesure où siôt arrivé au pouvoir
il a décidé de s'autonomiser de de se
débarrasser de ces deux alliés rwandais
ougandais qui commençaient à devenir à
la fois extrêmement gourmand et
extrêmement gênant euh et il a appelé à
son secours puisqu'il n'avait pas de
force armée à cette époque un certain
nombre de pays africains l'Angola la
Namibie le Tchad même et cetera et
cetera et donc de 1998 à 2002 il y a une
grande empoignade en quelque sorte
africaine au Congo on a appelé ça la la
seconde guerre du Congo euh oou la
première guerre mondiale africaine
puisqu'il y avait à peu près neuf neuf
armées africaines qui étaient présentes
et qui s'affronaient dans différentes
régions pas seulement dans l'Est du
Congo mais aussi au sud du Congo euh et
donc cela a duré jusqu'à ce qu'il y a un
accord de paix l'accord de Sun City et
qui
a permis le retrait de ces armées
étrangères et a organisé une transition
de 2003 à 2006 donc les armées notamment
ougandaises et rwandaises qui étaient
très présentes dans l'Est du Congo sont
sorties à cette époque-là euh elles sont
sorties mais l'économie de guerre qui
avait été mise en place a perduré et
notamment dans les trois provinces dont
je vous parle euh et cette économie de
guerre est basée était alors à cette
époque essentiellement basée sur
l'exploitation des ressources minières
du sous-sol de ces régions qui est une
exploitation extrêmement facile euh
puisqu'elle se trouve à la surface donc
vous n'avez pas besoin de moyens
industriels il s'agit pas de creuser
profondément dans la TER pour les
extraires mais au contraire de gratter
le sol pour pour les extraires et donc
ce système d'économie de guerre qui
avait été mis en place a perduré malgré
le retrait de ses armées puisque un
certain nombre de groupes armé tout à
l'heure on parlait de plus de 100
groupes armés en effet dans toute cette
zone euh ont exploité ses ressources
naturelles l'armée congolaise aussi
s'est emparée d'un certain nombre de ces
sites miniers et donc l'économie minière
locale est devenue la base de cette
économie de guerre alors euh
progressivement cette cette situation
cette économie de guerre s'est
diversifieré euh et c'est ça qui
explique la longue durée si je puis dire
de ce conflit euh parce que il ne s'agit
plus maintenant simplement de
d'exploiter de manière illégale les les
ressources minières mais ça concerne
également le bois ça concerne également
le le le charbon de bois qui est un
marché de qui paraît anecdotique quand
on le dit comme ça pour nous mais qui
est un marché de plusieurs millions de
dollars dans cette région euh et il y a
donc du coup une un système de taxation
qui a été mis en place par tous les
belligérants et quand je dis tous les
belligérants je parle aussi de l'armée
congolaise qui consiste à taxer tout ce
qui rentre et tout ce qui sort de cette
région et donc de s'autofinancer vous
avez un mécanisme d'auto de cette
économie de guerre permet
l'autofinancement de tous les
protagonistes du conflit et euh si on
regarde les protagonistes de ce conflit
maintenant donc j'ai cité l'armée
congolaise évidemment qui est
contrairement à la loi euh extrêmement
impliquée dans cette économie de guerre
la loi congolaise interdit au militair
les activités économiques euh vous avez
donc plus d'une centaine de groupes
armées euh qui se divisent grosso modo
et je vais faire simple en deux
catégories vous avez des quelques
groupes armés étrangers euh donc des des
opposants burundais des opposants
rwandais et des opposants ougandais qui
se sont installés depuis très longtemps
dans l'Est du Congo et qui sont des
opposants armés qui on le mouvement armé
et qui se qui qui vivent là et qui
euh veulent ou prétendent exercer une
menace contre les régimes des
pays-voisins euh et puis vous avez
surtout les groupes armés congolais qui
sont les plus nombreux qui il y a 20 ans
s'appelaient les les ma ma et qui
maintenant s'appellent les wasazalendo
mais c'est la même chose et ce sont des
groupes donc formés par la
population local surtout d'origine
rurale et ce sont des milices grosso
modo euh milices qui ont une base très
souvent ethnique et puis autre
protagoniste de ce système de conflit
qui est je disais à la base un système
de conflit de ressources on se bat pour
contrôler les ressources économiques de
la zone ce sont évidemment les forces
armées des voisins qui
euh officiellement évidemment ne ne vont
pas au Congo mais marude très
fréquemment que ça soit l'armée
rwandaise ou même l'armée ougandaise
maraude sur la frontière parfois font
des opérations un peu dans la profondeur
ou parfois comme l'armée brundis sont
installé depuis plusieurs années au sud
kivou pour contrôler et lutter contre
leur opposition armée donc vous avez ces
deux catégories de groupes armé des
groupes armées étrangers des groupes
armées congolais l'armée congolaise et
aussi des armées étrangères qui mènent
des les opérations militaires mais
mènent aussi leurs affaires économiques
puisqu'elles font partie de ce système
de de prédation dont je parlais et qui
constitue la base de de l'économie de
guerre dans cette zone et qui explique
sa durabilité alors l'autre élément qui
explique cette cette durabilité du
conflit et son caractère structurel
c'est que au fil des temps c'est'est
créé évidemment comme dans toutes ces
situations de conflit qui dur la
conséquence de la durée c'est une
gouvernance hybride où vous avez
finalement euh des des provinces
entières qui si officiellement elles
sont sous l'autorité du gouvernement
dans la réalité sont un système de
gouvernance hybride c'estàdire de
gouvernance partagée entre les autorités
légales et des seigneurs de guerre et
donc vous avez comme ça toute une série
de de seigneurs de guerre en règle
générale c'est d'ailleurs un job qui se
transmet de famille en famille
c'est-à-dire que les les ma mail de
génération en génération se transmettent
le flambeau si je puis dire euh et donc
vous avez c'est cette gouvernance qui
est qui repose sur un consensus euh et
notamment un consensus économique sur
contrôle euh de l'économie de certains
territoires et vous avez comme ça des
des échanges même si en théorie l'armée
congolaise est censée lutter contre ces
groupe armé très souvent elle a euh une
relation d'alliance euh et notamment
cette alliance s renforcée depuis la
crise du M23 et elle a surtout parfois
aussi des relations économiques euh il a
été démontré par de nombreux rapports
des nations- Unies que une bonne partie
de l'armement des groupes armés provient
des stocks de l'armée congolaise de
l'armée congolaise leur vend des armes
ou leur en donneent en fonction des
circonstances euh donc c'est un système
de gouvernance hybride qui s'est
installé durablement dans la région qui
repose sur une coalition
d'intérêt entre comme je disais les
seigneurs de guerre et puis les
autorités officielles civiles et
militaires de de la région euh mais
aussi de Kinshasa ceci ne se fait pas
sans l'aval de Kinshasa et aussi avec
l'implication des des pays voisins et en
particulier de l'Ouganda du Burundi et
du Rwanda qui font partie aussi de ce
système de de prédation violente dont le
business model et là je résume très
rapidement pour parce que on n pas
tellement le temps de rentrer dans le
détail mais pour vous le résumer c'est
un business model qui consiste à
extraire des ressources de manière
violente et est commercialisé par la
fraude c'està-dire par la contrebande
essentiellement contrebande et donc vous
avez toutes ces ressources naturelles
que ce soit le minier ou le forestier
dont l'essentiel passe par en
contrebande dans les pays voisins de la
Tanzanie jusqu'à l'Ouganda grosso modo
donc vous avez grosso modo ce qu'on
appelle une mafia d'élite mais qui est
une mafia régionale qui concerne
l'ensemble des Grands Lacs et pas
simplement les Grands Lacs d'ailleurs on
peut l'étendre aussi à la déramification
Inter international maintenant puisqu'il
y a de plus en plus par exemple de
chinois qui opèent dans le secteur
minier artisanal dans cette région et
donc on voit assez bien les
ramifications internationales et
l'essentiel de l'or qui est extrait de
cette région de manière violente comme
je disais une extraction violente prend
la direction de Dubaï où il est vendu
massivement sur cette place aurifère
mondial la dernière élément qui explique
la durabilité du conflit c'est que là
aussi les fait de durée de tout conflit
c'est de créer des groupes sociaux qui
reposent économiquement et
sociologiquement sur le conflit et donc
comme je le disais on peut faire
remonter le conflit à 1996 donc 1996 ça
fait une génération déjà et donc il y a
toute une génération de congolais dans
cette région qui a été socialisé dans et
par la violence dans et par la violence
et donc il y a une normalisation de la
violence vience et une très grande
euh habitude du recours à la violence
dans les comportements sociaux et
j'appellerai ça une une une sorte de de
normalisation de la
violence qu'on voit par exemple quand on
étudie les kidnappings qui ont lieu dans
la région traditionnellement le
kidnapping c'est un crime contre les
riches c'est-à-dire qu'on kidnappe des
gens qui ont les moyens de payer et ce
qu'on a vu se développer depuis 5 ou 6
ans dans la région c'est quelque chose
d'assez inhabituel inédit par rapport au
au phénomène du kidnapping ailleurs dans
le monde c'est que on kidnappe même des
pauvres pour le rançonner le peu
d'argent qu'ils ont ou même leur anonner
leur leur bétail et cetera donc on on a
même un phénomène de kidnapping de
pauvres ce qui montre bien à quel point
la violence a pénétré les les relations
sociales euh et alors l'autre élément de
de cette normalisation de la violence
c'est évidemment que les questions
économiques se règle par la violence les
questions de compétition économique se
règlent de manière violente en règle
générale entre les différents acteurs
quand il y a des différents économiques
on n'hésite pas à recourir à la violence
et pour conclure parce que je pense que
j'arrive un peu à la à la fin de de mon
temps comme vous le savez il y a
actuellement un groupe armé qui fait
beaucoup parler de lui dans la presse
qui s'appelle le M23 qui a une histoire
ancienne dans laquelle je vais pas
rentrer mais pour vous résumer
ce groupe armé euh a déjà été à
l'origine de la première crise post
grande guerre si je puis dire qui avait
eu lieu en 2008 et à cette époque il
s'appelait le CNDP il a été à l'origine
de la deuxème grande crise post-conflit
en 2012 avec la prise de Goma ce groupe
armé a pris la ville de Goma et après
avoir été en sommeil pendant 10 ans il a
ressurgi en 2021 et en 2022 il s'est
approcha de nouveau de Goma alors ce
groupe armé fait beaucoup parler de lui
parce que il est soutenu par le Rwanda
par l'armée rwandaise
euh un tas de choses le le prouveent si
vous voulez on pourra en discuter tout à
l'heure euh et ça constitue évidemment
la première menace pour ou la menace la
plus sérieuse si je puis dire
actuellement pour l'armée congolaise et
il y a une situation de face- àface
euh dans lequel dans laquelle il y a des
forces d'interposition il y en a deux
euh il y a les casques bleus de la
Monusco et puis il y a depuis peu les
forces de l'East African community qui
ont été appelé au secours par le
président tisekedi qui trouvait que les
casques bleus ne servaient à rien et
donc il lui fallait une autre force mais
revirement de situation après seulement
un an d'installation de cette force
armée régionale le président chissekedi
leur a demandé de partir et donc ils ont
commencé leur retrait il y a une semaine
et donc ça va créer peut-être une
nouvelle situation
tactique dans la zone du du Nord kivou
alors que les élections en effet ne sont
pas loin
euh ne sont pas loin d'arriver donc on
va sans doute avoir des nouveaux
développement tactique je pense au début
de l'année prochaine une fois que les
les élections seront passées avec ce
retrait de la force de l'AST African
community et l'appel au secours par le
président tissekedi de la sadeek où il a
dit bon ben je la force de l'IST African
community ne me satisfait pas donc j'en
appelle une autre la sadeek la Sadek a
dit un oui théorique théorique parce que
sur le plan pratique il ne semble pas
encore décidé à déployer des troupes et
il y a encore des désaccords entre les
membres de la SADC sur un éventuel
déploiement militaire dans l'Est du
Congo donc je vais m'arrêter ici je
pense que je suis arrivé au bout de mes
15 minutes et comme ça on va pouvoir
avoir du temps pour les questions merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup ça ça rejoint ce
que je disais tout à l'heure à la fin de
mon propos liminaire sur la question de
la corruption qu'on appelle comme on
veut mais qui quand même
à une forte odeur de de corruption de
mon point de vue mais sur la question de
la région de
l'iturie du Nord kivou et cetera j'ai
j'ai effectivement eu aussi beaucoup de
témoignage sur la présence de beaucoup
de chinois mais pas forcément des
grandes entreprises chinoises mais
beaucoup de petits auto-entrepreneurs
qui paraît-il s'installe et il reste
définitivement et ils font des fortunes
assez colossales d'ailleurs et en en
grattant juste effectivement vous le
disiez la la surface de la Terre c'est
assez assez inquiétant mais je crois que
j'ai un certain nombre de prise de
parole et d'ord Alain Casabonne
ou c'est une question très rapide après
avoir écouté vos exposés que j'ai trouvé
très intéressant il y a une question que
je me poseris est-ce qu'il y a une lueur
d'espoir d'optimisme alors j'ai bien
noté dans la chanson des enfant mais
c'est un peu limité est-ce que vous
pouvez percevoir quelque chose qui
permettrait d'aller mieux parce que ça
assez désespérant comme
tableau mer je vous propose de passer de
faire une série j'ai quatre questions
donc on va poser on va faire les quatre
question et puis après vous répondrez
donc ensuite j'ai Olivier sigolti
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs de de vot de votre description
aussi précise qu'inquiétante moi
j'aurais une question synthétique vous
avez l'un et l'autre évoqué le le
recours à la Chine à la fois dans le
cadre des élections à venir mais aussi
dans le cadre de de l'extraction
minière est-ce que vous pouvez préciser
peut-êtreos vos connaissances en matière
d'influence étrangère et et sur quel
secteur activité ces influences
interviennent-elles mer si Philippe
folot j'ai pas vu mais qui do
être pardon excuse-moi je t'avais pas vu
merci monsieur le Président euh tout
d'abord merci pour cet éclairage par
rapport à à ce pays qui est un pays je
dire éminemment éminemment important
pour l'Afrique
subsaharienne vous avez parlé des des
élections vous avez
parlé jeis dire des des enjeux relatifs
au fait parce que dans un pays où il y a
pas d'état civil c'est effectivement
difficile d'avoir un collège électoral
euh j'allais
dire totalement
euh qui qui qui qui soit respecté par
par tout le monde et incontestable et
incontesté moi je voulais vous poser une
question sur une personnalité dont vous
avez cité le nom qui va être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle et et qui euh
euh que j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
du reste pour les 20 ans de la fondation
Pierre fabrebre qui est euh le le le
docteur Denis muqueger euh euh et et et
je je voulais savoir si pour vous parce
que le combat qu'il mène par rapport euh
à la lutte contre cette terrible arme de
guerre qui est le viol des femmes et et
est quelque chose d'éminemment important
et essentiel et c'est du reste pour cela
qu' il a reçu le prix Nobel de la paix
et et et dans ce cadre-là est-ce que
pour vous euh il peut avoir des chances
et est-ce qu'il incarne quelque chose
d'autant plus que lui il est originaire
de de l'Est du du pays euh et et et et
et donc est-ce qu'il peut y avoir une
une perspective par rapport à sa
candidature venant de la société civile
dans ce dans ce milieu euh marqué par la
corruption et tout ce que vous venez de
décrire merci Philippe et puis pour
terminer Michel gréot mais je passerai
ensuite à une série d'autres questions
euh la mission de maintien de la paix de
l'ONU en République démocratique du
Congo présente depuis 99 a déclaré
récemment avoir signé avec le
gouvernement un plan de retrait de ces
14000 casque déployés dans le
pays essentiellement dans l'Est le Congo
est en pass de connaître des niveaux
records de violation grave vérifié
contre les enfants pour une 3e année
consécutive
excusez-moi en 2023 enfants tués violés
enlevés c'est une alerte d'une agence
humanitaire des des Nations
Unies
excusez-moi il y aurait sur place une
assistance pour toute victime identifiée
conformément à la stratégie globale des
Nations Unies pour l'assistance et le le
soutien aux victimes d'exploitation et
abus sexuel pouvez-vous nous dire si
vous avez des éléments sur cette
assistance
merci je sais pas comment vous
répartissez les réponses mais je vous
laisse faire
euh merci pour ces questions je vais
essayer de d'y répondre à certaines
d'entre elles un peu un peu dans le
désordre
euh Denis Meger euh gynécologue célèbre
dans le monde entier euh j'ai eu le
juste pour une anecdote bien avant le
prix Nobel j'ai eu le bonheur de le de
lui donner les insignes de la éion
d'honneur à l'ambassade de France il y a
c'était en 2009 et c'est pour dire que
la France avait déjà reconnu ses mérites
depuis très très longtemps donc un
hôpital près de bouavu à Panzi hôpital
qui reçoit des femmes venant de de
différents endroits en particulier du
Sud
kibou deux de deux deux anecdotes utiles
pour dire ce que fait la France nous
avions mis en place avec lui un
dispositif de déploiement c'est la
France qui avit financé dans l'ensemble
de la de la province de déploiement de
rapide de d'infirmiers de médecins pour
au bénéfice des femmes qui étaient
victimes de viol dans un lapse de temps
très très court je pense que les vous
comprendrez ce que je veux dire avant
que le viol ne produise des effets
dramatiques ça c'est une chose l'autre
chose que j'ai le plaisir à et un
certain honneur à rappeler c'est qu'à
quel kilomètres de l'hôpital de Panzi il
y a un hôpital qui était tenu par une
Française une bretonne Marie Joseph bet
qui faisait exactement la même chose qui
est le docteur meegé et qui a souhaité
rester dans anonymat complet quand je
lui ai proposé de recevoir la Légion
d'Honneur alors fusé pour des raisons
voilà elle refusait absolument mais la
seule chose que j'ai pu faire c'est de
lui installer un équipement électrogène
et après un équipement solaire qui la
rendait totalement indépendante lui
permettait d'opérer du matin du lundi
matin au samedi soir avec une équipe de
deux chirurgiens donc il y a d'autres
choses denisug la personnalité
emblématique bien connu mais ça sais
qu'il y a d'autres choses et que la
France a fait beaucoup de choses dans ce
domaine alors Dony Mog à mon avis a peu
de sens parce qu'il n'a pas l'expérience
politique et l'expérience le
savoir-faire qui permettrait de de
d'obtenir sur un scrutin un tour ce ce
rappel où il y a à côté de lui d'autres
candidats particulièrement costaud je
pense à Martin fayoulou et à Moïse
Katumbi voilà donc mais c'est vrai qu'il
incarne il est beaucoup à
l'international il est pas toujours
extrêmement connu si ça vous intéresse
il y a un film de Thierry Michel un
réalisateur belge qui va être présenté
cette semaine je crois à l'Assemblée
nationale et qui en partie raconte son
histoire voilà donc pour vous répondre
je pense qu'il a peu de sens mais je me
demande quelque foois pourquoi il s
embarqué dans cette dans cette affaire
ce qui m'amène à parler de la Monusco la
monisco en fait il y a des casques bleus
au Congo depuis 1960 vous interrogez des
casques bleu canadien le Canada vous dit
on est là depuis on a toujours été là au
Congo d'une manière ou d'une autre avec
des noms qui ont pu changer il est
peut-être bon de savoir que la France
était représente le Conseil de sécurité
au Congo et donc en charge de du suivi
de la Monusco et de la préparation du
renouvellement de son mandat et la
question qui a toujours été posée et qui
n'a jamais été véritablement résolue et
ce qui explique que beaucoup de
Congolais demande le départ de la
Monusco c'est que la Monusco n'est
jamais sortie de son rôle de protection
pour avoir un véritable rôle
d'intervention
et ce que lui a été reproché et donc les
les casques bleus pakistanais Kenan
sénégalais qu'on peut voir sur le site
sont très souvent cantonnés dans leur
caserern plutôt que d'être très actif de
manière euh euh comment dirais- comme
force
d'intervention préventive sur sur le
site d'où d'où ce que vient de dire
Thierry vercoulon l'appel au pays au
pays voisins puis ensuite aux pays de
l'Afrique australe en particulier de
l'Afrique du Sud
euh en ce qui concerne la Chine alors on
dit beaucoup de choses sur la Chine
lorsque en en 2009 euh la Chine avait
promis un contrat mirrifique de 9
milliards de dollars pour construire des
infrastructures hôpitaux universités et
cetera nous étions parvenus euh je ve
dire les les les les ambassadeurs
occidentaux à faire à ramener le le
contrat 6 milliards de dollars et parce
que la contrepartie de ce l'assise la
garantie de ce financement était reposé
sur des ressources minières du pays en
particulier des ressources de cobalt et
de cuivre du du Katanga vous savez que
le le le Congo est le premier producteur
au monde de cobalt qui est un minerai
particulièrement recherché par
l'industrie électronique et un rapport
l'année dernière de la Cour des comptes
du du Congo démontre
que il y a eu pour 6 milliards de
dollars
d'acquisition de capitaux dans le
secteur minier mais en revanche il y a
pas 6 milliards de dollars de
contrepartie sur des infrastructures on
est même sur des chiffres qui sont
inférieurs aux milliards de dollars et
donc il y a une une récrimination très
fondée des autorités les autorités
congolaises vis-à-vis de la Chine accusé
de ne pas avoir respecté dans ce deal
qui était un deal très important c'est
ces
obligations je vais juste pas pas abuser
j'aurais pu parler du mais je serait
peut-être
tiouond en
parlerit faut savoir quand même à propos
du du du Randa il y a un rapport que que
vous aez pu citer qui est le fameux
rapport mapping qui n'a pas été publié
mais qui est un rapport des Nations
Unies qui est une qui est très
controversé mais qui est affiché
régulièrement par les autorités
congolaises pour conforter les
accusations qu'ils ont en ce qui
concerne les interventions du Rwanda qui
aurait effit selon certaines
statistiques c'est certains démographes
Canadiens entre 4 et 5 millions de morts
non pas du
fait des résultant de la guerre ce sont
des morts qui peuvent être dont
l'origine peut-être le système de santé
complètement défaillant et cetera mais
les perturbations qui ont été provoqué
par l'entrée des troupes randais à
partir de 96 aurait provoqué un drame un
drame humain bien plus important mais
la comparaison est
extrêmement difficile à faire bien plus
important à celui du du génocide de 94
donc il y a une espèce de de
revendication des Congolais qui disent
mais et nous et nous et nous et nous
dans l'histoire le le Randin bénéficie
d'une rente compassionnelle culpabilité
incarnée notamment par la France
culpabilité occidentale de ne pas être
intervenu quand il fallait dans le drame
et mais le roi a bénéficié aussi d'une
rente économique une rente minière
importante mais et nous et nous
congolais où nen sommes-nous et ce ce
cri ce cris des congolais est fréquent
disons il y a deux poids de mesure dans
la façon dont on gère la situation
régionale alors quel espoir et je je
reviens à votre question évidemment
c'est très difficile de répondre je je
répondrai
euh de deux manières la première c'est
que ce pays quand même un miracle 63 ans
après il est dans les frontières de 1960
en dépit de toute cette histoire qu'on
raconte ça c'est un miracle et il y a en
dépit de l'archipalisation du pays hein
euh quand vous êtes à à à Boma euh vous
êtes pas à Gomin vous êtes à 2000
km du pays et sans aucune infrastructure
de communication ni train ni ni véhicule
autrefois à l'époque des Belges on on on
allait de Boma à à luubumbashi qui
s'appelait pas comme ça à l'époque mais
en album à luubumbashi en voiture on
faisait une nuit au milieu à Kanga
aujourd'hui il est absolument impossible
d'aller à lubumashi donc en dépit de ce
de l'éclatement de ce pays il y a
quelque part une identité congolaise sur
lequel pourrait se construire un
sentiment national c'est pour ça que
j'ai cité l'hyne national et puis
l'autre chose ce que nous savons
généralement ce que nous savons pas
faire par les chercheurs qui font du
terrain c'est d'identifier quels sont
les les énergies moi je crois beaucoup à
la démocratie par le bas la construction
de nouveaux modèles démocratiques
susceptible de pouvoir satisfaire les
besoins les plus essentiels gestion de
l'eau gestion des décés gestion des
handicapés situation des femmes emploi
des jeunes et cetera et quand vous
faites l'inventaire de toutes ces
énergie dans la capitale près de plus ou
moins 10 millions d'habitants peut-être
12 on ne sait pas quand vous fait vous
capitalisez là-dessus sur ce que
j'appelle des initiatives populaires
vous voyez qu'elle révèle elle révèle
des modes d'organisation qui peuvent
s'apparenter à ce que nous on appelle la
démocratie c'est-à-dire la
redevabilité la reconnaissance de
l'effort la redevabilité des services
rendus l'alternance à certain n de
choses qui sont des embryons alors ça
mettra du temps c'est pas spécifiquement
congolais mais et et ça trouve une
incarnation dans toute une série de de
de domaines euh qui peuvent être le
théâtre qui peuvent le domaine
artistique je ne ventterai pas la rumba
congolaise bien évidemment qui est la
musique africaine et une musique
congolaise si vous mettez de côté la
musique sénégalaise et la musique
cfrique sud-africaine la musique
africaine est une musique congolaise il
y a c'est simplement une illustration de
cette énergie vitale de ce pays et c'est
probablement en
cherchant cette où se positionne cette
énergie qu'on pourra identifier l'épaule
de l'épaule de de développement
démocratique
oui euh pour à la question de des
influences étrangères si on regarde
uniquement le le domaine économique
comme on disait tout à l'heure la la RDC
depuis sa création est une cleptocratie
minière donc elle a toujours eu des
partenaires étrangers qui étaient très
importants parce que très impliqués dans
son fonctionnement économique euh donc
ils ont changé au fil du temps les
évidemment depuis la la colonisation il
y a eu des des grands changements euh
dernièrement sur les les 20 dernières
années donc il y a eu en effet l'arrivée
des Chinois avec un méga contrat en
effet de de 9 milliards de dollars qui
avait été signé pendant le premier
mandat du président Kabila
euh ceci est en effet maintenant remis
en cause par le le président tisekedi
euh et mais comme il est aussi à la
recherche de de de partenaires d'autres
partenaires de substitution dans le
domaine économique qui s'est tourné vers
les les amirats Arabes Unis euh et vers
le Qatar aussi d'une certaine manière et
euh et donc il a signé un un contrat
très important avec une société émirati
qui est en fait le faunet de la famille
royale émirati pour l'exportation de
l'or euh qui vient des kivou euh c'est
un contrat là aussi qui a 90 derrière je
crois que il s'élève à 2 milliards de
dollars et qui a un contrat comme le
contrat chinois c'est-à-dire ressources
minières contre infrastructure
et qui aura probablement le même sort
que le contrat chinois c'est-à-dire que
il y a déjà des exportations d'or très
substantielles qui sont faites sur Dubaï
il y aura probablement pas beaucoup
d'infrastructure euh donc c'est le
nouveau le nouveau partenaire si je peux
dire important ça devient les les
Émirats arabes unis et et d'autres pays
arabes et ça on le voit c'est une
tendance très intéressante qu'on voit se
développer depuis que la Chine commence
à réduire la voilure sur le continent et
réduire c'est prêt on a eu 15 ans enfin
les les gouvernements africains ont eu
15 ans d'argent chinois facile où ils
allaient à Beijing et on leur faisait
des lignes de crédit maintenant avec
l'évolution de la situation en Chine et
le nouveau contexte international les
Chinois ont décidé de mettre fin à
l'argent facile et de demander à ce
qu'on les rembourse euh et donc beaucoup
de gouvernements africains maintenant se
tournent vers les pays du golf pour
trouver de l'argent facile donc voilà
c'est l'évolution un peu des nouvelles
influences étrangères dans le domaine
euh économique évidemment dans le
domaine sécuritaire on peut en parler
aussi si vous le souhaitez si vous avez
le
temps très bien excusez-moi mais je vois
le temps passer et les rang se dépeupler
donc je passe la parole pour une
question rapide à Olivier cadiic et puis
ce sera autour de Jean lu cruel oui
c'est c'est un complément parce que
justement je voulais vous poser ma
question sur colvisie et puis la
capitale du cobalt puisqu'on sait
queeffectivement c'est une ressource
nécessaire pour les batteries
électriques et et on observe il y a eu
plusieurs reportages qui ont qui sont
passés cette année on observe
effectivement que maintenant les Chinois
contrôlent à peu près 80
% de la ville et vous l'avez très bien
dit sans contrepartie sans les
contreparties attendues en
infrastructure ceci étant il y a des
redevances minières et donc où va
l'argent actuellement de ces redevances
minières est-ce que comptetenu de de ce
qu'on voit des des gens qui perdent leur
maison qui sont déplacés est-ce que vous
ne pensez pas que la population pourrait
se révolter puisque ça pourrait être une
illustration de ce que vous décriviez
peut-être comme nouveau modèle
démocratique est-ce que vous ne pensez
pas qu'on pourrait voir voir ce ce
phénomène et et enfin quand même sur le
business model avec le côté
chinois puisqu'on parle de Dubaï il faut
quand même savoir que lors de notre
commission d'enquête sur le narcotrafic
cette semaine et il a été dit et il
apparaît que Hong Kong ne répond
absolument plus dans aucune demande
d'enquête sur les trafics financier donc
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas aussi des
connexions directement avec Hong Kong
merci merci et puis Jean-Luc pour
terminer merci la RDC est riche de son
immensité territoriale et de son
potentiel environ ental ce pays possède
40 % du massif forestier tropical du
continent africain le bassin du Congo
représente 1/5e de toutes les forêts
tropicales du monde et contient plus de
la moitié de la biodiversité d'Afrique
ainsi que 10 % de la biodiversité
mondiale la RDC est également riche en
ressources minières cuivre cobalt
Coltane minerau stratégique minéraux
stratégique pour assurer la transition
énergétique de nos sociétés or les
États-Unis la Chine exerce un monopole
sur l'accès à ces métaux précieux la
France qui est un qui a un ancrage très
relatif avec des flux vraiment très
insuffisants avec la RDC dans ce pays
enant compté parmi les partenaires
incontrônable de ce pays en raison des
enjeux environnementaux et
géostratégiques pouvez-vous nous
indiquer comment la France et la RDC
peuvent-elles nouer un partenariat
mutuellement bénéfique garantissant
d'une part la France assurer sa
transition énergétique et d'autre part
permettant à la RDC de se doter d'une
stratégie
d'industrialisation en phase avec les
défis environnementaux je rappelle
également que en matière énergétique 80
% de l'énergie produite en RDC est
consommé par les mines et naturellement
il n'y a pas de développement industriel
ou de sans énergie donc c'est
véritablement également un sujet je vous
remercie merci beaucoup et j'ai une
question à laquelle vous répondrez par
oui ou par non mais on a entendu parler
évidemment de de de tentative
d'implantation de Wagner à pointe noire
dans le en République du Congo est-ce
qu'il y a eu des tentatives connues
euh dans dans République démocratique
merci beaucoup et rapidement alors je
crois qu'il y a une question de GIS moi
je change un petit peu donc de focus
c'est par rapport donc à l'influence
donc française euh Cu des instituts
français des alliances donc vous avez V
brièvement la francophonie mais on en
est on en est où et petit constat par
rapport à ça merci
beaucoup quelques quelques réponses en
laissant à à Thierry Vircoulon le soin
de de faire les commentaires qui qu'il
souhaite faire on a parlé du bassin du
Congo le le deuxème bassin forestier du
du monde après
l'Amazonie 10 % des forêts de la planète
mondiale ce n'est pas que la la RDC
puisque le le bassin du Congo déborde au
Congo au Gabon
centra-afrique sachez que le bassin du
Congo absorbe tous les gaz à effet de
serre produit par tous les véhicules de
la planète c'est dire l'enjeu de de de
ce bassin des 145 d'ectares du du du
bassin contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
penser une vision un peu cartographique
démontre qu'il y a une une reforestation
du
bassin dans ses
marges relativement rapide qui vient
compenser la déforestation qu' on laissé
entendre tout à l'heure à propos de du
sbon de bois en particulier dans le cœur
du bassin donc il y a un potentiel qui
est qui est important et qui a reconnu
puisqueà Dubaï la COP 28 donc la semaine
dernière a reconnu que la mise en cause
de bassin serait un désastre planétaire
et notre chef d'État a annoncé comme
pour la papoisie nouvelle- guuinée qu'il
fallait mettre en place un paquet
forestier de 60 millions de dollars pour
rémunérer la la République démocratique
du
Congo afin qu'il protège sa
forêt l'idée l'idée qui est importante
c'est un bien public universel dont la
gestion mérite rémunération donc cette
idée est acquise cette reconnaissance
est
acquise deuxième chose en ce qui
concerne la France bon on se rappelle
que la la France n'est pas un pays
minier et donc à part des sociétés de
services n'est pas présente sur le le
domaine minier mais Thierry on dira
peut-être plus parmi les acteurs il faut
ajouter le Canada qui lui en revanche
c'est un pays minier et l'a Australie
qui lui aussi est un pays minier et
l'Afrique du Sud qui donc ce n'est pas
une affaire uniquement euh chinoise donc
il y a très souvent une alternance de de
de de partenaires euh parmi le potentiel
du pays qui n'a pas été cité que n'ont
pas été cité c'est son son potentiel
hydroélectrique puisque le barrage
d'Inga qui serait à l'extrémité de la
carte que vous voyez lorsque vous voyez
Boma l'extrémité euh du fait des rapides
qui euh qui naissent après Kinshasa sur
le fleuve Sénégal le barrage d'ingar
arrêt un potentiel trois fois supérieur
au plus grand barrage chinois celui des
des Trois Gorges et pourrait s'il était
mis en œuvre véritablement pourrait
satisfaire les besoins en électricité de
la moitié du continent en tout cas
surtout sur la partie australe euh c'est
un barrage qui fait partie de
l'imaginaire collectif dont on parle il
y a déjà un barrage il y a quatre
turbines il y en a deux qui marchent
actuellement ENF la dernière fois que
j'y suis allé mais il y a là ça ça a
rajouté dans le potentiel que représente
ce pays à l'échelle de du pays mais
également à l'échelle de l'ensemble de
la région juste pour dire un mot sur la
France
euh je vous remercie d'avoir posé cette
question à propos des instituts français
il y a quatre instituts français
à au Congo il y en a un que j'ai créé à
à Goma un autre àoukavu qui j'ai
également créé un autre que nous avons
installé à lbumbachi et puis un
ancien très important qui est celui de
la Gombé à Kinshasa qui est un des plus
beaux centre culturel enfin un des plus
pas beau il est moins beau que celui de
brasaville qui est en face mais qui
coûte la qui coûte extrêmement cher en
climatisation c'est un centre culturel
très ouvert et qui est extrêmement
dynamique et reconnu par l'ensemble des
artistes et des intellectuels comme un
lieu un des lieux contournable j'ajoute
une vingtaine d'alliances françaises qui
sont des associations de droit local
mais qui régulièrement nous sollicitent
pour avoir du matériel des éléments des
bouquins et cetera et on en trouve en
particulier dans la les les régions est
de
litourie et des deux et des deux KIV
vous il y a une demande de France il y a
une appétence de France euh je dirais de
manière presque alternative à à la
relation que les congolais très très
particuliè entretiennent avec la
Belgique qu'ils appellent les cousins en
dépit du fait que la colonisation fut
parmi les plus dramatique dans
l'histoire dans l'histoire du monde
euh c'était plus qu'un régime d'apartail
c'était un régime d'une rare violence
comme vous le savez les les Congolais
ont gardé une relation particulière avec
les la RDC simplement simplement le le
notre chef d'État était récemment en
mars dernier à Kinshasa et il a été
assez chèement reçu ça c'est le ça c'est
une une forme d'expression que l'on
retrouve aisément dans les pays
d'Afrique de l'Ouest ancienne colonie
française mais c'est la première fois
que je l'entendais dans un pays qui
n'avait pas d'histoire colon avec la
France et lorsque le président
chekedi dans un échange assez houleux
avec Emmanuel Macron lui a dit lui a dit
regardez-nous autrement en nous
respectant en nous considérant comme de
vrais partenaires et non pas toujours
avec ce ce regard paternaliste avec
l'idée de toujours savoir ce qu'il faut
pour nous donc il va falloir qu'on si on
veut dynamiser cette relation avec ce
pays modifier très sérieusement la
posture l'attitude le langage les mots
mais c'est un exercice qu'il convient de
faire avec l'ensemble du continent
africain pour sortir de cette critique
récurrente euh qui nous est qui nous est
opposé et qui révèle un certain
ressentiment anti-français donc l'avenir
de cette relation euh repose très très
largement sur sur le le renouveau qui
appppelle certains députés je pense à
Bruno fou et et Madame taburau dans leur
le rapport qu'ils ont remis y a il y a
un mois euh je crois qu'il y a eu un
débat ici euh au Sénat avec Madame la
ministre des Affaires étrangères je
crois que il faut là aussi dans ce pays
aussi Sion on veut garder répondre à
cette appétence cette demande de France
très forte et il faut il faut savoir lui
parler correctement
merci merci beaucoup merci euh pour
compléter très rapidement on estime
actuellement que 70 % du secteur miniier
congolais est contrôlé par des intérêts
chinois euh et notamment il faut faut
rappeler que les États-Unis avaient fait
un investissement massif d' 1,2 milliard
de dollars dans une mine au Katanga au
sud de pays qui est vraiment le cœur
économique du pays hein on parle
toujours comme je disais des kivou mais
vérité c'est que le cœur économique du
pays il est dans la zone du copper belt
euh ils avaient acheté une mine de
cobalt et de cuivre pour 1,2 milliards
au début de cette année qui de ceèc
pardon qu'ils ont vendu aux Chinois en
2016 euh et donc une des raisons aussi
pour lesquelles les intérêts chinois ont
énormément progressé dans le secteur
minier c'est la sortie des acteurs
anglo-saxons qui ont vendu leurs actifs
la seule grande entreprise minière
occidentale canadienne du coup
s'appelait bandro qui était dans le
secteur horifaire dans les kivou a vendu
aussi ses actifs à une société chinoise
donc il faut il faut quand on regarde
l'évolution économique récente il faut
avoir ça en tête euh en ce qui concerne
Wagner il y a eu des des prospections
euh Wagner pour s'implanter au Congo et
et trouver un appui au Congo euh il y a
eu quelques éléments qui ont montré ça
notamment par exemple le
transfert du numéro 2 de l'ambassade
russe à bangi à Kinshasa euh qui était
la personne qui était le correspondant
de de Wagner du côté Affaires étrangères
russe euh également une manifestation
prorusse organisée au début de la guerre
en ine dans les rues de Kinshasa euh par
des des des gens qui étaient soudoyés
pour ça euh et puis des campagnes
surtout des campagnes sur les réseaux
sociaux lorsqu'il y a eu la crise du
M23 qui visait l'Union européenne et la
France avec un narratif assez classique
qui disait si vous n'avez pas d'armes
pour lutter contre le M23 c'est à cause
de l'embargo des Nations Unies qui
est-ce qui fait cet embargo
diplomatiquement c'est l'Union
européenne et la France et cetera donc
c'était une manipulation évidemment sur
les réseaux sociaux et ceci provenait de
de Russie euh voilà mais il n'y a pas eu
de vraie implantation parce que le le
président
tisekedi reste quand même du côté
occidental de la barrière si je peux
dire euh et donc ne n'a pas permis à
Wagner de s'implanter même si évidemment
il y a un certain nombre de
personnalités congolaise liées
historiquement à la Russie qui ont fait
les intermédiaires et euh et on servi de
de point de contact pour Moscou
euh en ce qui concerne la la le secteur
minier dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
au Katanga enfin dans l'ex Katanga ce
qu'il faut savoir sur ce secteur minier
quand on anal c'est que vous avez à la
fois là-bas un secteur industriel et un
secteur artisanal donc il y a à la fois
comme je disais pour les kivous des gens
qui grattent le sol avec une pioche et
puis euh des grandes sociétés qui elles
ont des mines industrielles et cetera et
les deux
ne sont pas si séparés que ça
c'est-à-dire que par exemple vous avez
des sociétés industrielles qui rachètent
la production des artisans miniers et
cetera donc des fois il y a évidemment
des situations de confrontation quand
les artisans miniers décident de d'aller
sur les concessions minière qui sont
possédés par des sociétés donc là il y a
évidemment des frictions et cetera mais
il faut savoir que il y a quand même un
système d'équilibre entre les deux qui
existent qui aussi connaît des épisodes
violents donc vous avez aussi a là-bas
des milices communautaires qui sont des
milices minières vous avez aussi l'armée
congolaise qui est louée par un certain
nombre d'entreprises industriel pour
pour se protéger leurs emprises et
cetera et cetera donc il y a une il y a
aussi un niveau de violence lié à ce
secteur minier mais il y a un système
d'équilibrage si je puis dire qui fait
que on n pas c'est pas une région qui
connaît les violences structurelles que
connaissent les kivou par exemple
dernière chose sur le bas du Congo en
effet le principe qui est on compense on
préserve le bassin du Congo en échange
de compensation financière est acquis ce
qui n'est pas acquis c'est c'est la la
la préservation du bassin du Congo
c'est-à-dire que quand on on étudie le
taux de déforestation on voit qu'il est
assez important et que la première cause
de déforestation du bassin du Congo
c'est la croissance démographique c'est
la croissance démographique donc même si
ce principe ce deal est acquis au niveau
international entre d'un autre côté on
touche pas on protège le bassin du Congo
et on compense financièrement il se peut
aussi qu'à un moment on se rend compte
que on compense financièrement quelque
chose qui est en train d'être réduit par
la force des choses force des choses
étant la
démographie merci beaucoup merci
messieur c'était particulièrement
intéressant et je pense que c'est bien
qu'on ait pu faire un focus sur ce pays
qui malheureusement je pense concr
sérieusement que ce soit dans les médias
ou dans l'opinion particulièrement
oublié alors que c'est sans doute un
pays d'une richesse incroyable
malheureusement vous l'avait démontré
particulièrement pillé comme le son un
certain nombre de pays africains
maintenant notamment par des intérêts
chinois un pays qui maintenant depuis je
pense la le début la fin du 19e début du
20e a été particulièrement j'allais dire
maltraité je pèse mes mots et donc c'est
important qu'on puisse aussi remettre
j'allais dire au-dessus de la pile cette
question euh congolaise donc merci pour
ces propos particulièrement intéressants
et très enrichissants et on reçoit euh
au Sénat tout à l'heure avec à la
présence du Sénat tout à l'heure le
président de du Sénat de la République
du Congo donc pas très loin de là qui
lui semble-t-il est plutôt fait euh ce
soit plutôt tourné vers le vers le
Rwanda qui n'est pas forcément un un
pays euh très amis avec la République
démocratique du Congo mais en tout cas
merci beaucoup pour ces propos et mes
chers collègues je vous garde quelques
secondes parce que j'ai on a deux
rapports à à à attribuer et donc il faut
que je le fasse merci Monsieur en tout
cas pour votre passage ici et puis merci
pour vos travaux et vos
recherches